edit habite sur la côte nord est le
magazine souvent en ligne elle voit des
jouets en soldes dans une grande chaîne
la livraison est gratuite pour tout
achat de plus de 49 dollars
parfait elle en profite pour faire ses
achats de noël facture totale 106
dollars au moment de payer
elles ne pensent pas à re vérifier le
montant total grave erreur
les frais de livraison de 176 dollars
s'ajoute parce qu'elles se trouvent en
région éloignée elle s'en aperçoit en
lisant le courriel de confirmation le
lendemain à diori soldes et la chaîne de
jouets refusé sa commande pourtant rien
dans son site ne donne à penser que des
frais aussi élevés peuvent être facturés
rien sauf cette mention minuscule qui
mène à une autre page où ceux ci est
noyée dans un long paragraphe pas très
explicite le fin mot de l'histoire
quand un site vous offre la livraison
gratuite ce n'est pas toujours un cadeau